it seemed primed for a sequel in 2005
but nearly 20 years later fans are still
waiting for Keanu Reeves as Constantine
to Dance with the Devil again good
Hollywood finally be ready to make it
happen in 2005 Constantine was a
moderate box office hit but evidently
Warner Brothers Executives considered it
as a self-contained film and not a
viable franchise starter 17 years later
however Warner Brothers Pictures bosses
Pamela Abdi and Michael DeLuca prefer
sat internal opinion and in September
2022 it was announced that a sequel was
in the works with the original Star
director and producer Keanu Reeves
Francis Lawrence and Akiva goldsman
respectively all involved of course
around three months later the hierarchy
of power in the DC Universe majorly
changed James Gunn and Peter saffron
were appointed the heads of Warner
Brothers subsidiary DC Studios and they
announced an ambitious slate of upcoming
projects Peter and I along with a group
of very talented writers have started to
map out an eight to ten year plan of
what DC Studios will be their release
schedule included an extensive list of
films and TV series revolving around
characters like Superman Batman
Supergirl and Swamp Thing nowhere in
their plan with titles set for release
between 2025 and 2027 was there any
mention of a Constantine sequel needless
to say fans started getting worried but
that's one of Warner Brothers
Representatives told Entertainment
Weekly that Constantine 2 was still very
much in the works although it was likely
to fall under the umbrella of DC
elseworlds a category meant for films
like Joker and the Batman that aren't
part of the DCU so that means a sequel
is definitely happening right well not
so fast in March 2023 Keanu Reeves sat
down with comicbook.com and said
Constantine 2 was no longer a sure thing
when after the film was moving forward
Reeves replied I was hoping it would but
we don't know yeah we're trying a big
reason why a Constantine movie hasn't
happened yet or at least why one didn't
end the production years ago is because
of complex issues over the rights of the
franchise as characters John Constantine
originated in hellblazer a title
published by vertigo Comics until it was
taken over by DC Comics that Comics
giant has interned a division of Warner
Brothers where last Latter-Day Star Wars
and rebooted Star Trek producer JJ
Abrams had a deal in place to develop a
justice league dark Universe with Abrams
at the helm plans were in the works for
several films and HBO Max series
featuring the team of Supernatural
oriented characters such as Dr Fate
Zatanna and ugastic Constantine one of
the first entries in The Saga on which
Abram spent two years developing was
going to be a Constantine show but in
September 2022 HBO Max said no to
Abram's justice league dark approach
around the same time however Warner
Brothers announced that they had ordered
a sequel to Lawrence's 2005 film with
Abrams on board as a producer of course
if that doesn't pan out perhaps Abrams
is some sorts of Constantine curse Keanu
Reeves has proven himself a tireless
advocate for a Constantine sequel
fighting the good fight since 2005. I
love playing Constantine I'd love to
have the chance to play Casa team he
recently spoke with a total film about
his personal lobbying of Warner Brothers
Executives and said that he kept asking
almost every year in 2021 Stephen
Colbert asked Reeves about the
possibility of a sequel on The Late Show
no one will make that movie
and I've tried I've tried Stephen wow
Reeves isn't the only actor who's
considered showing up for part two Peter
Stormare who portrayed Lucifer in the
original Constantine told scream rant in
2022 that discussion's about a sequel
began within a year after the first
film's 2005 release and that interest
from producers gradually increased the
DVD sold pretty good and social media
started to come around and Constantine
was always something that people did
love so mayor also said that sequel
talks grew a specially promising around
2007 2009 and 2011 without production
ever officially beginning the Lucifer
actor shared their Reeves was a
principal agitator urging producers to
not wait too long still mayor
hypothesized if we have the same
director the same writer the same cast
we might be able to pull it off thus a
problem of doing Constantine too this
might be too late in April 2023 Rachel
Vice who played twins Isabelle and
Angela Dawson discussed the possibility
of another film with comicbooks.com but
said that her involvement month doesn't
seem likely in February 2023 Akiva
goldsman the reported screenwriter for
the Constantine sequel signed a
production deal with Warner Brothers and
he told deadline that one of his top
priorities was getting the new
Constantine off the ground with director
Francis Lawrence and star Keanu Reeves
discussing the themes he and his
collaborators would like to consider he
said Francis and Keanu and I had been
pretty deep in the story breaking stage
the character is very much Keanu and the
way he and Francis saw the world of Good
and Evil and the wonderful and authentic
Noir where there is a World Behind the
world of Good and Evil coexists with our
world right up close further elaborating
on what we could expect Francis Lawrence
told the rap that he's shooting for a
mature and heady film one that earns in
our rating explaining that as of late
2022 a script had yet to be written he
teased we have germs of ideas and
dedication now if we were to guess about
the plus we've got a few possibilities
JJ Abrams the listed producer on the new
Constantine film which was announced
just after the death of the filmmaker's
HBO Max projects there's a solid
Constantine 2 could concern itself with
justice league dark spooky gritty Hero
Squad and its dealings with a
supernatural it could also address the
first film's Cliffhanger ending in a
post-credits scene Constantine visits
the grave of deceased Charles Kramer
that's when Chas suddenly appears
growing wings and flying away
foreign
's got good news in July that progress
have been made on the project with a
story for the sequel finally being
broken with Keanu Reeves and the
original Constantine director Francis
Lawrence amid the ongoing writer strike
Akiva goldsman shared in an interview
with the playlist my pens are down so
there's nothing to do but Francis Keanu
and I have broken Constantine too I just
haven't started typing yet sadly we live
in a miserable hellscape for our
Constantine 2 with Keanu Reeves has yet
to materialize the hard bitter Nexus has
made enough of a positive impression
with fans of comics derived media
however that the hellblazer has
consistently popped up in various
television projects in 2014 NBC debuted
a weekly Constantine TV series with Matt
Ryan subbing in for Reeves unfortunately
this series couldn't bring in viewers at
add only 13 episodes Ryan would continue
to portray the character on various
dc-based shows broadcasting the CW
including Arrow Batwoman The Flash and
legends of tomorrow where John
Constantine became a regular character
Four Seasons Ryan additionally voiced a
character and animated projects like
justice league dark and Constantine's
city of demons while Jenna Coleman
portrayed a gender-flip's take on the
figure Joanna Constantine on Netflix's
adaptation of Neil gaiman's the Sandman
foreign